атмосфера майже як в армії команди
однострій чіткі правила так звичайні
цивільні люди навчаються Одні із
найнебезпечніших професій У роботі де
мінера
26-річна Юлія раніше працювала
фінансистом у рідному селі Богданівка
під броварами разом з батьками пережила
російську окупацію після цього
звільнилася з роботи аби піти навчатися
на демінера я пішла на співбесіду нікому
дома нічого не сказала
Ну мені сказали чекайте дзвінка я
дочекалась дзвінка звільнилась з роботи
зі своєї потім вже вдома сказала Тому
батьки ще досі перебувають в шоковому
стані
Юлія одна з 15 дівчат серед 90 людей у
групі з важким металудетектором у руках
дівчина ретельно перевіряє кожен
квадратний метр своєї робочої ділянки
поки без справжніх мін ось ми знайшли
сигнал безпосередньо нам потрібно його
відмітити щоб ми його не пропустили бо
після нас не залишається
ні одного сигналу не можу залишатися Цей
курс міжнародного гуманітарна
організація Halo trust пропонує усім хто
хоче стати де мінером спершу безкоштовно
навчають потім працевлаштовують
В'ячеслав з Херсона відпрацьовує
найскладніший метод розмінування повну
екскавацію так шукають проти піхотні
міни вони можуть перебувати на глибині
до 7 см а то і глибше
на 2-3 см вперед знизу вверх на це може
цілий день і два дня і три дня крупівка
робота не лякає В'ячеслава для нього
найстрашніше позаду разом із дружиною і
двома доньками він провів два місяці в
окупованому Херсоні до війни чоловік
працював на Новій Пошті електромеханіком
за словами В'ячеслава відділення пошти
росіяни пограбували у перші дні окупації
спочатку більш-менш було у місті ну тихо
майже а потім
почався терор ми виходили на мітинги
потім стали стріляти
в людей на мітингах
з родиною виїхав до родичів на Київщину
тут випадково дізнався про вакансію
демінера пройшов співбесіду і потрапив
на навчання ми
запропонували там інші
должности на співбесіді Ну а я так кажу
що Та ні мені хочеться домінером з
самого початку така думка була щоб рідні
території бо вже після деокупації після
війни мати можливість розмінувати
допомагати тому що я знаю кожен метр
рідного краю херсонщину всю І я знаю там
Ну Мої діти будуть жити переміщатись і
це дуже важливо з 2015 року
працювала на Донбасі організація
розмінувала 420 гектарів земель
працювали над цим так само цивільні
українці Які навчилися домінуванню з
нуля халу стало роботодавцем для понад
400 місцевих серед них і Марина у
минулому економіст А нині інструкторка
яка передає свій досвід іншим Лана
состояния здоровья головне стан здоров'я
якщо у людини є проблеми з колінами вона
алергік який не переносить укуси бджіл
бо ж ми працюємо на природі де все на
свіжому повітрі якщо вона астматик чи є
проблеми з серцем чи тиском зрозуміло що
цим людям буде набагато складніше
працювати 24 лютого Марина з дітьми
виїхала з рідного Краматорська а її
чоловік пішов на фронт нині жінка мріє
повернутися додому хоча після трьох
років розмінування її батьківщина тепер
знову забруднена мінами мама бідна
образливо що ми розмінували Донецьку і
Луганську області і зараз доведеться
заново робити коли поля які ти проходив
своїми колінами і руками тобі доведеться
заново розміновувати Але ми не
розчаровуємося для нас Головне щоб наша
Україна перемогла і ми повернулися
додому
Марина розповідає Що за час її роботи в
Хало жоден Демір не загинув і не
травмувався усе завдяки суворим
стандартам І протоколом наприклад ось
так повільно і виважено студент Сергій
перевіряє наявність розтяжок ось такими
рухами
від Землі до рівня
очей
демінери не сапери вони не беруть до рук
боєприпаси міни не знешкоджу
ють лише знаходять небезпечний предмет
відмічають і викликають саперів ДСНС
Сергій батько трьох дітей свою майбутню
професію вважає безпечною хоча
зізнається дружина хвилюється але я знаю
з досвіду що стандарти холотрас вони
дуже високі в плані безпеки головне це
безпека Ну і засоби захисту і обладнання
тут найновіше і якщо дотримуватися
процедур безпеки то
Ну скажімо так на 99% це безпечно це
безпечна робота
Сергій родом з Кривого Рогу за фахом він
геодезист працював із підприємством яке
через війну зупинилося тож чоловік
переїхав до столиці і на сайті з пошуку
роботи знайшов вакансію демінера
по-перше це робота на свіжому повітрі
постійно не в кабінеті за комп'ютером
там де в тебе очі вже не бачать екрана
але треба робити немає абсолютно
психологічного тиску ніякого стосовно
там плану роботи стосовно якоїсь норми
нормувань Таких немає тому працюєш
спокійно зарплата демінера стартує від
24 тисяч гривень за відрядження є
надбавки
устати до керівника групи чи інструктора
робота триває у дощ і спеку але
припиняється під час зимових морозів
поки до них далеко майбутнє домінери
зокрема і Юлія готуються до фінального
іспиту до нього дійшли не всі студенти з
понад 100 людей у групі на початку
залишилися 90 Юлія розповідає декому
робота стала не до душі але не їй я
знала що я буду триматись в принципі
холоду жари роботи я не боюсь тому мені
не так важко як здається моїм батькам
вчитися наполегливу дівчину мотивують
стіни власного будинку нещодавно
відбудовані після прильоту але все ще
посічені уламками Юлія говорить що хоче
якнайшвидше очистити свою землю від
нагадувань про окупацію краще їх швидше
прибрати і забути ніж просто сидіти і
думати що вони десь я а ти не знаєш що з
ними робити для цього ми навчаємося щоб
знати що зробити щоб могти їх
[музика]
ідентифікувати та хоча повідомити туди
куди треба група з якою навчаються Юлія
вже четвертий випуск демінерів на
Київщині пройшли навчання і стали до
роботи близько 300 людей Утім в
масштабах України цього замало кажуть
демінери адже за світовою статистикою
один день активної війни це місяць
ретельного розмінування для якого
потрібні сотні робочих рук